hey youtubers it's Charlie we got to
talk all about attack on gorilla city
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet welcome to the jungle
there were so many Planet of the Apes
references in this I am so happy with
what they did I know a lot of you
expected some of the fight scenes to be
a little bit longer but it's just a
prelude to part two which is going to be
next week so if you're new to the
channel I do flash videos every week be
sure to subscribe to get everything I
even do giveaways to I'll explain at the
end of the video so let's do top 10 WTF
and comic book Easter eggs I'm so happy
with this two-parter you have to
consider it like a 2-hour TV movie just
because so much of this story is in part
2 like I told flash always think ahead
now if you will open the breaches and
very soon the troll city will fall
before
and let me know if you guys think the
audio is okay I changed it just a little
bit so it should sound a little better
or never tank a realist City explainer
so we learned there's a city of super
smart aides they've captured Harrison
wells you actually learned that they
sent this cryptogram the same way the
team flash sent a cryptogram into the
multiverse that's how they got HR to
come to their earth in the first place
like you send a coded message but the
ones that the guerrilla sent is super
advanced so it gives you an idea of just
how smart they are it's not that they're
as smart as humans is that they're super
smart and they have psionic abilities
meaning that they can control other
people so they are a huge threat and
obviously the whole thing is a big long
con on graz Park but the way they
disseminate information through the
episode you learn that they wanted to
tease Harrison wells capture him use him
to get to earth one leading us into
number nine trying to avert the future
future news headline city of recovering
from gorilla attack maybe if we can
change more things we can save iris but
I really like this reverse flash idea so
there was a lot of shout outs to the
Harrison wells reverse flash from season
one he is the one that said the taking
action to avoid some big future
catastrophe only leads to something
equally as bad happening that's why you
don't change the past but team flash
this season has learned you might be
able to change small things but the
really big things usually end up
happening in different ways even if they
didn't go down the way you thought they
would just one of many callbacks to the
reverse flash in the episode Barry using
his signature move to take down solovar
Grodd referencing him father taught me
well always think ahead so the reverse
flash of season 1 is still very present
even though we haven't seen them at a
long time he puts a team together I love
all the Indiana Jones shoutout Planet of
the Apes tell me you're going to Planet
of the Apes there's no way I'm staying
behind the whole thing here Julia is
worried about Caitlin I know they're
teasing some sort of relationship but he
is really concerned for her in a genuine
way I love the way they tagged out at
the end - you should fear me well why
don't we fear each other over a giant
steak together number 8 welcome to the
jungle the gates of gorilla city so in
addition to this being looks like a
really awesome wide shot giant Star Wars
Guns N'Roses
Easter Egg it is so much fun how they
cram all those references
all backs the season - in those opening
moments before they get thrown in the
cells like she remembers meeting earth
to killer frost what happened to her oh
she is super dead now so you see Caitlin
is starting to get more more worried so
even though it seems like they're taking
a lot of steps to prevent Caitlin from
becoming killer frost she's actually
more and more using her powers in small
ways which is making it worse
progressively so it sounds like one of
those things that we're going to arrive
at no matter what like whatever ends up
happening Caitlin's going to keep having
to use her powers to help her friends
and she's going to get closer and closer
to killer frost so I already did a video
about the flash prophecy about someone
betraying the team and talked a little
bit about killer frost Cisco stuff so
we'll add a link at the end of the video
but number seven way back on earth one
Wally and Jessi teaming up Iris telling
him to lock it down this is all the pre
lewd to her staying on earth one but you
get the sense that she's super bummed
out and she's not really sure what Wally
thinks of her they figure it all out
it's all relationship stuff so easy like
this or you hate it it's totally cool if
you're not down with this but they just
want to let you know that they're going
to be cool with each other and she's not
jealous or anything he just she's not
sure what Wally thinks of her because
she's just worried that he's more in
love with being a speedster and of
course he's like all that bull crap so I
do like the character development that
Wally and Jessi are getting I'm a real
big fan of just a quick scare occur so
it'll be interesting to see how they
uses the next couple weeks just be
careful if you've been watching the
behind the scenes stuff please don't
post spoilers in the comments back to
earth-2 number six Grodd captures the
team and explains the grand plan kill or
be killed
so levar is going to come to your earth
he wants to attack you I love people
like Caitlin because they help me I
never want to see harm come to them so
this is what you have to do you have to
kill them in the arena and you start to
wonder because Grodd is one of Flash's
biggest enemies in the comics what's
going on here is there some big twist
behind this and it becomes a little more
clear number five when so lebar mr.
Keith David enters I was so happy with
Keith David being cast on the show he
has one of the most awesome voices ever
of course he should be so levar so he
walks in in his super surprise to see
team flash like he did not expect more
humans so he accepts Flash's challenge
in number 4 flash vs. so levar is a
pretty epic fight I know
you wanted it to go longer but just
remember that this is sort of the
prelude to the bigger part 2 episode
which is next week so they weren't going
to waste too much time with this arena
fight but they just want to let you know
what a badass most of these gorillas are
so lavars very smart he has all the same
powers as gorilla grodd and they're sort
of a dichotomy
so Grodd is this really evil
power-hungry gorilla
so lavars the wise one who doesn't want
to attack humans but it's also very wary
of them too he would kill them if he
needed to but he doesn't seek war the
way that Grodd does he doesn't care
about revenge it was so funny watching
solovar just shut Barry down all his
normal tricks weren't working try the
lightning throws Tillie had to fight
dirty
using a reverse flash trick that might
come back again later in the season
doing things that you never thought you
would do
learning from your enemy's tactics so
just remember that for when he's
fighting savat are later this season
look at the work on his shield here this
is so crazy in the Spiritist too they
actually the statues spear tips when
they entered the city look like flash
lightning bolt
so the craftsmanship is amazing and you
learn from the fights that the Flash's
had with Grodd in the past - so levar
has all those skills and look how
quickly he anticipates the flashes next
move like he can just time him down to a
tee so he thought that Barry was being
super beta or he went down too fast this
is just them showing you that so levar
is that much smarter than everyone else
so the flash runs real fast
that doesn't make him a genius he's only
a genius for 30 minutes at a time and he
did not read any books about fighting
super guerrillas when he entered that
arena we'll probably see some better
strategizing when we get around to part
2 of this episode usually the team has
to come together before they can take
down something this big gorilla grodd is
one of the biggest threats that they
face all season next to saboteur the
only thing that makes avatar worse is
that he has knowledge of the future and
he just flat-out faster than all of the
speedsters put together but number 3
Grodd reveals his true plan he is pissed
that flash did not kill so levar mostly
because even though he's in charge now
so levar is still alive to challenge him
it will probably be key to defeating
Grodd in episode 2 next week solar bars
always really important for fighting
Grodd in the
comics now there been a lot of issues a
lot of stories where the flashes fought
broad by himself with the help of other
people
he even teamed up with the Rose but the
thing is is that for a lot of those
stories Sola bar was dead he came back
during blackest night during a brief
period but so levar is the person that
you want on your team if you're going to
be fighting Grodd we'll see what they do
with them Grodd made all those
references about the hell that he was
living in living under so lavars rule
living in one of Sola bars cages so in a
reversal of that he may have just thrown
Sola bar into a cage of his own but
plans revealed rods been running a long
con he wants revenge against people in
earth one that put him in cages so he's
going to burn central city to the ground
number two until team flash is able to
escape by make believing that Barry is
dead remember Caitlin had to use her
powers again meaning that her killer
frost condition is getting worse even
though she didn't have to actually kill
someone that would have been crossing
the edge maybe that's a hat tip for the
future she accidentally killed someone
and that makes her become killer frost
but how crazy was at when Cisco
suggested that they kill him I'm the
only one that can get you back so you
have to kill me he actually meant that
but that's not something that you can
come back from so of course everyone is
like hard path we are not killing anyone
so they try to trick Grodd and I love
how they get home and everything is
super nice Jesse quick even says that
she's going to stay they get the kiss
with Wally even iris tells Barry I don't
know how you can be so positive and he's
like I know we can defeats avatar now
because we won so hard
Julian probably had the biggest
rule-breaking moment when he said they
were very smart but we were smarter like
the minute you call out a victory like
that you knows that they're going to
take it right back and yank the rug out
from under you so number one post
credits teaser Grodd has verse 19 gypsy
he's wearing his armor there is a legion
of guerrillas ready to roll out and they
are coming to attack central city that's
actually the name of the next episode
attack on central city so it is going to
be crazy the whole thing here with gypsy
is they don't let you know about the
twist after the big twist like oh my god
she's helping them so I don't think
she's evil she wouldn't want to destroy
a central city so either he's
blackmailing her or he's outright
controlling her
mine because just because Cisco and
gypsy have all those powers doesn't mean
they're not susceptible to being taken
over by Grodd let me know in the
comments though what was your guy's
favorite moment I love the way they
plotted out grodd's arc in this episode
how he seems like he's the one that's in
trouble and needs help but then reveals
that he was behind this grand plan all
along
always one step ahead of the flash so
even though the TV show is called the
flash really Grodd is the main character
of these two episodes so it is going to
be epic to see how they take them down
in part two maybe it'll have something
to do with so levar and it'll all come
back around to the idea of then being
able to change events change things for
the better save people without
completely being able to escape those
future headlines so they can always
change small things but there are some
things that they probably will not be
able to change so the gorillas will
smash up Central City really good but
they might be able to save some people
from dying but it was a great episode
it's going to be fun to see Jesse quick
on the TV show every week for at least
the next couple weeks I don't know
exactly how long she's going to stay but
what's going to happen for the next
couple of videos as the schedule is
going to be a little bit different I'll
do a flash trailer video next and I'll
do legends of tomorrow and then I'm
probably going to wait to do my arrow
episode till Thursday morning there's a
new round of the injustice giveaway
going on right now all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video it's for a copy of the
game congratulations to last week's
giveaway winner Malachi McNeal
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details so I'll post that flash
trailer video tomorrow morning while you
wait for that you can click here for
Wonder Woman aries and you can click
here learn all about this avatar
prophecy thank you so much watching
clips I thought I'll see you guys in the
next video